coup de projecteur à présent sur la
Maison des Femmes de Tours ce lieu dédié
à l'accueil des victimes de violences
physiques ou psychologiques est ouvert
depuis le 1er juin 2021 au CHRU de Tours
ce lundi une invitée de marque est venue
découvrir son fonctionnement l'actrice
Camille Cottin un coup de pouce
médiatique de la marraine de ce service
pour récolter des fonds plus
d'explications avec les la Turquie
Camille Cottin marraine de la Maison des
Femmes de Tours c'est maintenant
officiel alors une séance photo s'impose
l'occasion pour l'actrice française de
montrer son soutien aux équipes de
Bretonneau c'est un projet qui me touche
énormément c'est passionnant parce que
il y a un accompagnement à chaque étape
il y a un accompagnement juridique
psychologique il y a une prise en charge
des enfants pendant les rendez-vous
très admiratif de ce qui a été mis en
place je trouve ça très intelligent et
je pense qu'il faudrait qu'il y en ait
absolument partout dans chaque ville un
accompagnement global et individualisé
pour toutes les femmes victimes de
violence voilà le cœur du projet de ce
service du CHU un lieu ouvert en juin
2021 et depuis le nombre de rendez-vous
ne cesse d'augmenter en 2022 plus de
1400 consultations sont réalisées soit
plus d'une centaine de femmes
accueillies par mois donc il y a un
besoin qui est important et donc l'idée
c'est vraiment de pouvoir accompagner
ces femmes et puis également leurs
enfants parce qu'il y a souvent des
enfants dans la boucle ce type de
structure où tout est centralisé ou tous
les acteurs pour sont présents au sein
d'une unité facilite le parcours des
femmes et donc leur permettre vraiment
de pouvoir sortir des violences pour
continuer à prendre en charge toutes les
victimes la Maison des Femmes souhaite
déménager pour s'agrandir et construire
de nouveaux locaux toujours sur le site
de Bretonneau une cagnotte est ouverte
avec pour objectif de récolter un
million 300.000 euros en espérant un
début des travaux en fin d'année